[موسيقى]
في عالم يوجد به ما يقرب من
9 ملايين تطبيق للهواتف المحمولة
لتعبئة هواتفنا
، يكتسب نوع جديد من التطبيقات زخمًا
واحدًا يقدم العديد من الخدمات للعملاء
في مكان واحد ، حيث
يقوم التطبيق الفائق بالشراء الصحيح الذي
يدفع ثمن الطعام الذي يأكل
البقالة وهم  تسهيل المدفوعات وإجراء
المعاملات بسهولة أكبر
يمكن أن تصل التطبيقات الفائقة إلى 500 مليار من
إجمالي الإيرادات بحلول عام 2025
وفقًا لماكينزي مع النمو في
آسيا والأسواق الناشئة ، بدأت
شركة واحدة في دبي بالفعل
في الاستفادة من هذا النمو ،
ونحن نرى أن كريم هو التطبيق الفائق الرائد
في  تم إنشاء جميع البلدان في الشرق الأوسط
كخدمة نقل ركاب قائمة على موقع الويب
في عام
2012 واستحوذت عليها أوبر في عام 2020 ، تقدم كريم الآن
خدمات
توصيل المطاعم والبقالة
بين المدن
والمعاملات الرقمية
لعملائها عبر أكثر من 100 مدينة
أطلقنا خدمة واحدة نحن  أطلقنا
خدمة أخرى أطلقناها خدمة ثالثة
على التطبيق الفائق ثم بسرعة كبيرة
تخلق
أسبابًا للأشخاص
لاستخدام خدمات متعددة من خلالك ، بدأت الشركة في خدمات التطبيقات الفائقة تدريجيًا حيث ضرب جائحة 19 السري أعمالها الأساسية في الربيع الماضي منذ ذلك الحين ، يقول كريم إن عدد المستخدمين ارتفع بمقدار 900 مستخدم ليصل إلى 48 مليونًا بينما في آسيا ، أصبح السوبر في السوق ناضجًا بالفعل مع عمالقة مثل wechat alipay والاستيلاء على السوق في الشرق الأوسط ، لا تزال المنافسة منخفضة واستغل كريم هذه الميزة للتوسيع ، أدركوا أن هناك فرصة حول المحفظة وحول تسهيلات الدفع لتمكين المزيد من المعاملات لتكون قادرة على المنافسة عالميًا ، يقول شوماخر إن التطبيقات الفائقة تحتاج لإضافة المزيد من الخيارات مثل دفع الفواتير والخدمات المصرفية الرقمية لجذب المزيد من المستخدمين ، فكر في جميع الخدمات الأخرى التي تستهلكها وفي مرحلة ما حتى وجهة نظرك للاتصالات السلكية واللاسلكية قد تتبع ذلك من خلال التركيز على هذه الخدمات وعلى تردد مستخدم أعلى يهدف كريم إلى تقويته مكانته كواحد من التطبيقات الفائقة الرائدة في الشرق الأوسط آنا  ستيوارت سي إن